the following is a conversation with
nick carter
who is a partner at castle island
ventures
co-founder of coinmetrics.io and
previously a crypto asset research
analyst
at fidelity investments he's a prominent
writer
speaker and podcaster on topics around
decentralized finance
and especially bitcoin quick mention
of our sponsors the information athletic
greens
for sigmatic and blinkist check them out
in the description to support this
podcast
this conversation with nick carter is
part of a series of episodes on
cryptocurrency
that is a small journey of exploration
i'm on because i find decentralized
finance
and especially bitcoin fascinating
technically and philosophically
especially because it may be the very
mechanism that achieves
a global decentralization of power
giving more sovereignty to the
individual
and making our systems more resilient to
corruption
manipulation in general to the darker
side of human nature
please let me also address something for
a few minutes
that happened recently that's been
weighing heavy on me
if you find me annoying to listen to
please skip to the actual conversation
with nick
i had a recent podcast episode with
anthony pompliano
where we spoke about bitcoin and life
in general for three hours i was curious
inspired
positive or at least i tried to be as i
usually do
someone clipped out out of context a
short segment of me mumbling something
about having a phd and i started getting
mocked
online because that made it convenient
for people
to mock me for being yet another
quote-unquote
expert who learns about bitcoin and
thinks he knows everything
i almost never mentioned that i have a
phd except to make fun of myself
as i was doing or at least trying to do
in the full context of the conversation
i brought up grad school as a random
example of one of the many journeys i've
taken
that was hard but where the destination
was in itself
not very useful i was saying i enjoy
exploring with a curious mind
and i'm willing to be patient to learn
to listen
to humble myself with knowledge for the
sake of knowledge
itself grad school was an example of
that
the phd means nothing at least to me
i never call myself an expert or at
least try not to
because that would be dumb because i
know how little i
know i'm not a influencer
or a thought leader or whatever else
silly self-aggrandizing label people put
on their linkedin
i try to be the opposite of what i was
mocked for
i tried to think deeply about the world
to look for the beautiful ideas in the
minds of others
and to be inspired by them i wanted to
say all this because
psychologically it struck a bit of a
blow
it made me realize that even when i
approach things with love
i may be mocked i may be derided i may
be taken out of context
or even lied about but the growing
platform this is sadly only increasing
i now have learned that there's people
who are waiting
for my missteps so they can point the
finger
laugh and say see i told you so that
guy's a joke
he's a fraud as a fellow human being
the knowledge of this is painful yes i
know
people tell me to toughen up and my life
has been about strengthening my mind in
the face of my limits
but i refuse to not be fragile and wear
my heart on my sleeve
it's who i am in some sense this is the
immune system of the internet
but let us be careful not to destroy the
good ones in the process
the bitcoin community had to endure many
years of attacks from quote-unquote
experts
and also fraudulent cryptocurrency
efforts that scam people
out of their money this created a
powerful immune system
that fought the attackers and the
scammers i understand this
and i also understand that one of the
beautiful aspects
of bitcoin is its community of humans is
decentralized
but some small part of this community
has come to enjoy the us versus them
battles
sometimes for the sake of the battle in
itself
this happens in political discourse as
well i understand
this but to my limited mind it sounds
like groupthink
which has powerful defense mechanisms
against bad ideas
but has dangerous consequences if taken
too far
as in many periods of human history that
i often talk about
where the us versus them thinking has
led to the suffering of many
again i understand the value of this as
many bitcoin is explained to me
but it's not the way i as a sovereign
individual
choose to walk in this life by the way
none of this podcast should be treated
as financial advice
before nick kindly gifted me with a
hundred dollars worth of bitcoin
in hardware form i didn't own any
i'll probably buy some bitcoin on cash
app coinbase and
other platforms and also transfer to a
hardware wallet
just to learn how to do it but other
than that i don't necessarily make wise
investment decisions
money is not a motivation for me
personally i try to avoid it actually
i'm grateful for every day i'm alive no
matter how much money is in my bank
account
for long stretches of my life that
number was very close to zero
and i was always fortunate to be free
and happy
so i encourage you to listen to people
much smarter than me
for actual good financial advice here
i'm just exploring ideas and as if this
has not already gone on too long
let me please make another comment on
the style of discourse among
some bitcoin maximalists on platforms
like twitter
that in my humble view i may be wrong
but i believe
is not conducive to the nuanced
empathetic exchange of ideas
i very much look for and enjoy again i
appreciate their style of discourse
i think i understand the value of it but
it's not my thing
so i don't want to engage in it i want
to hear the quiet voices in the room
i look for people to inspire each other
and when we disagree
i look for disagreement that is grounded
in respect
and empathy i think that mockery and
derision
destroys the possibility of those
nuanced conversations
it drives away the quiet thoughtful
empathetic voices
and i try to give those voices space to
be heard to shine
to exchange ideas whether we agree or
disagree
so if i happen to block you on twitter i
block you with
love honestly i will never speak poorly
of you
or even think poorly of you i would love
to hang out in person
give you a big ol hug and talk about
life over some beers
if you see or hear me say something
stupid which i'm sure i do often
or something you disagree with and you
still respect me as a human being
please show your love as i always do to
you but also send me some
links to blogs books videos podcasts
where people describe why my stated idea
may be totally wrong
i love this kind of long-form
disagreement i humble myself
every day by reading books and blogs by
people
much smarter than me sometimes it
strengthens my ideas
sometimes it totally changes them but i
always learn
this is a two long way of saying that
i'm here
trying to walk with grace and with an
open mind
a bit of patience and always love
if i make mistakes cut me some slack
like you
i'm only human allegedly
you